First of all, congratulations.
I saw the movie last week.
It is an astonishing piece
of art and technical wizardry.
Thank you. That's very.
That's very kind.
Yeah.
People seem to be connecting with it,
which is all we could have hoped for.
13 years after the first avatar
and five years
after starting production on this one.
How do you feel about what you're now
sharing with the world, Jim?
Are you satisfied with it?
Yeah.
I was satisfied before we put it out.
But that doesn't necessarily mean
that people
people are going to be interested.
You never know.
I mean, it's just the nature of our
our business.
That you never really know
until you put something out there
in the zeitgeist
if people are going to respond.
But it
it seems to be the right film
at the right time.
And I don't know
if that's
that sense of childlike
wonder that can engender in an audience.
Or maybe it's the emotional processing
that they go through when they watch it.
Almost everybody
that sees
it tells me that they
they cry or they tear up at some point.
So I think it's working on
on multiple levels.
So that's very satisfying.
I mean, I'm just sort of reeling
from the fact that I'm unemployed
for the first time in five years.
Let's talk about that for a minute.
You know,
you've obviously
had an extraordinary
history of successes,
but as you say, nobody knows.
We are nervous
when finally you had to share this
with the world.
Yeah, very.
I think you're all
I think any filmmaker
that says they're not nervous before
their film drops is is you know,
lying or or, you know, in denial.
Yeah. You of course you're nervous.
You know,
the zeitgeist
changes, people's tastes change.
We're in a.
Coming out of a COVID era,
but we're still not at full strength
in the, you know, theatrical community.
We're only running at about maybe
65 to 75% of what we used to be.
So we're trying to build that back.
Yeah.
So there's
there were a lot of variables,
a lot of factors
that made it quite daunting You say this
avatar is more emotional
than the first one.
And part of that
is that you have given Sully and Neytiri
a sprawling family of children.
Why did you decide to go that route?
Well, I think it's a couple of things.
I mean, one, you know,
they say write what you know.
And as a as a family man,
as a father of five,
this is something
that I'd never really dealt with that
I wanted to deal with.
I also wanted something
that would have a universal appeal
for people in any culture
or language
or religion
around the world,
because the Avatar audience
is a global audience,
which we're
seeing again on on this release.
And I just
I wanted the characters
to have stakes, like real stakes.
I wanted to deal with
with as much as the beauty and wonder.
On the one
hand,
I also wanted to do with something, deal
with something
deeper, you know,
which is like grief and loss
and how we process these deep bonds
between between each other.
One of the ways that you show
that emotion is through
a filmmaking
technique called performance capture.
And let's take a look at some of that.
It's fascinating You are very hard on
I'm the father.
It's my job.
What is this stunt story?
Oh, yes.
I'll be nice once and then I won't.
I know one thing
this family is our fortress.
How much harder is
that, Jim, than straight
CGI Computer-generated imagery?
And is it this performance capture?
Is it
worth all of the extra time and expense?
Well, that's really the big question.
I mean, I can talk for hours
about how we do it,
but we rarely talk about why we do it.
One of the big upsides of it
is that I take all of my cinematography
ideas and I postpone them
into a kind of a post-production.
So what I'm doing with the actors
is not photography,
it's not cinematography.
We're not doing dolly shots
and crane shots and all that.
I'm just working with the actors.
It's a very pure art form.
It's almost like a theatrical,
like a rehearsal for a stage play.
So as a
as a director, I'm not distracted
by all that other stuff.
I'm just focusing on character.
So I quite like it.
I'm not sure that it's
necessarily justified if you can.
If you could film something
with actors, by all means film it.
But I can't create these characters
any other way.
I can't create this world any other way.
And there's something about that
dreamlike experience
that people are having
where they're dreaming
with their eyes
wide open
and it looks completely real,
but it can't possibly be.
That,
I think, is a big part of the appeal of
these films.
Now, when Sam Worthington and Zoe
Saldana are doing a scene together
and you've got this camera
right in their face,
are they doing the scene together
or is each one do? Absolutely.
We work with everybody together
as much as possible, and that's critical
because when there's no set there
and there's no world there.
It's all about the actors
looking in each other's eyes
and getting that sense of that truth
and that emotional reality in the scene.
So we can capture up to 20 people
at a time, which means we can do
crowd scenes, we can do group
ensemble type scenes, we can do
one on one scenes like the ones that
you were looking at there.
So the
important the critical thing is
the actors have each other to play too.
And and that's
what allows them
to get to that deep truth of the scene.
Even, I think more than the first avatar,
you really portray the conflict
between nature
and Mann's
exploitation of natural resources.
And here's some of that
Protect the people
Let's get it done.
Your message?
Maybe it seems to me is even more dire
than it was in the first Avatar
13 years ago.
Yeah, well, look,
I mean, the world's not.
The natural world is not getting better.
It's suffering more.
And more every day
in terms of species extinction.
And we're really focusing
with this film on the ocean
and the creatures of the ocean.
The habitat of the ocean.
And it's not doing that
well on our on our world.
And we have to do better.
I mean,
I don't think the film is preachy,
but the message is clear
and maybe if people enjoy the film,
they go on the ride,
they enjoy the action
and the emotion of the movie,
but they come out
thinking, hmm,
maybe, maybe we do need to be less
destructive and more connected
to the natural world.
Avatar two
has grossed
according to the last numbers
I saw, about $1.4 billion.
It is an enormous hit.
But you have said you've set the marker
that it needs to make at least $2 billion
to break even to justify another one.
And that that, I guess, is
is the question. I have one.
Are you going to make that figure
of $2 billion and two
if you don't?
Does that mean
we're not going to see Avatar three?
It looks like
just with the momentum
that the film has now,
that will easily
pass or break
even in the next few days, actually.
So.
So it looks like
I can't wiggle out of this.
I'm going to have to do these other
these other sequels.
So I kind of know
what I'm going to be doing
for the next six or seven years.
And I'm sure that we'll have a discussion
soon, you know, with with the top folks
at Disney about,
you know, the game plan going forward.
For Avatar three,
which is already in the can.
We've already
captured and photographed the whole film
and then Avatar four
and five or
are both written
we even have some A4 in the can.
So, you know,
I think we can see that that
I think we've begun
a franchise at this point.
How crushing
and I hope
and you think it's not going to happen,
but how crushing would it be to
you personally if you didn't get to tell
the entire arc of the Avatar story?
Not so bad.
I mean, look,
I understand this business
and I understand the vagaries of it
and the variables.
And, you know, the old expression
you know, man proposes and God disposes.
You never quite know
what's going to happen.
I also believe in planning
for the upside,
not not sort of just making a movie
herky jerky
and then waiting to see what happens,
but plan for the upside and then accept,
except that if it doesn't work.
I read somewhere
recently that you said,
and let me get it right,
I don't want to do anything
but big swings.
What if at some point between now
and whenever
the economics of the business
were to be such that,
as you say,
we're at 60
or 70% of the pre-pandemic movie going?
If the economics of the industry
just becomes such
that it doesn't allow for big swings like
Terminator and Titanic and Avatar,
I think it's fine.
I mean, I'm a storyteller.
I love having a camera on my shoulder.
I love hand-holding.
I love working with actors.
You know,
I'll still be able to get a job
as a storyteller.
People still need their stories
and whether that's
whether they're being produced
strictly for television, for streaming,
I can live with that as long as everybody
else has to live with it.